>> Sean: THANK YOU BOTH.
SHELBY, THANK YOU.
ALSO TONIGHT, BARACK OBAMA
BEGINNING ANOTHER ROUND OF
SOFTBALL INTERVIEWS TO PROMOTE A
WHOPPING 760 AGE PAGE BOTH AND
REWRITING HISTORY ALL ALONG THE
WAY.
OF HE GOES ON "60 MINUTES" AND
BARACK COMPARED THE PRESIDENT TO
A DICTATOR.
THE LACK OF "INTO CONSTITUENTON
NORMS."
HANNITY LESSON, IT WAS YOU WHO
ARE TARGETED JOURNALISTS.
DON’T REMEMBER 2013 REVEALED
YOUR ADMINISTRATION SECRETLY
SPYING ON JOURNALISTS AND THEN
FOX NEWS REPORTER COLLEAGUE
JAMES ROSEN.
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
INSTITUTIONAL NORMS, BARACK?
HOW ABOUT SPYING ON THE INCOMING
ADMINISTRATION FRAMING MICHAEL
FLYNN USING A FAKE
HILLARY CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION
DOSSIER TO SPY ON A CANDIDATE OF
PRESIDENT-ELECT AND THEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO FUEL A RUSSIA
HOAX.
BECAUSE BARACK, I DON’T REMEMBER
YOU ARE FRANKLY ANY DEMOCRAT
SPEAKING OUT ABOUT THAT.
SAVE US THE LECTURES, BARACK.
WHERE IS YOUR VOICE WHEN IT WAS
NEEDED?
FOR YEARS, YOUR PARTIES NEVER
ACCEPTED THE ELECTION RESULTS.
FOR YEARS, NEVER ENDING
HARASSMENT.
UNPRECEDENTED.
IN YOUR PARTY AND YOU, YOUR
SILENCE WAS DEAFENING.
SO YOUR FEIGNED OUTRAGE TODAY
PRETTY MEANINGLESS TO EVERYONE
EXCEPT MAYBE THE SYCOPHANTS THAT
ACTUALLY MADE THE 780 PAGE FOUR.
DID YOU HEAR ABOUT THAT?
NO, CRICKETS.
ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT RUSSIA?
NO, UKRAINE.
QUID PRO QUO JOE?
NO.
ZERO EXPERIENCE HUNTER?
LAWLESS ACTS, VIOLENCE AGAINST
POLICE AND DEFINING THE POLICE,
ABUSE OF POWER, CORRUPTION,
BIGGEST ONE IN THE HISTORY OF
THE COUNTRY?
NOT A WORD.
MOB, MEDIA, DEMOCRATS, ALL
UNITED AS ONE.
NO LONGER INTERESTED AND HAVE
NOT FOR A LONG TIME BEEN
INTERESTED IN GETTING TO THE
TRUTH, FAX OF ANY SERIOUS
INVESTIGATION.
THEY TAKE ON THE BROADEST
HYPOCRISY.
GOVERNOR SARAH PALIN NOW.
A GOVERNOR, MAN, YOU’RE LIVING
IN BARACK’S HEAD.
I THOUGHT FOR A WHILE I LIVED IN
BARACK’S HEAD BECAUSE HE KEPT
MENTIONING ME FOR A WHILE DURING
HIS RUN FOR OFFICE.
THROUGH PALIN, IT SEEMS AS IF
THE DARK SPIRITS THAT HAD LONG
BEEN LURKING ON THE EDGES OF THE
MODERN REPUBLIC PARTIES ENOUGH
PHOBIA AND PARANOID CONSPIRACY
THEORIES COMING FROM THE
DEMOCRATS AND THAT’S IN BRIDGE
STATEMENT.
TOWARD BLACK AND BROWN FOLKS WAS
FINDING THEIR WAY TO CENTER
STAGE, SHE HAD NO IDEA WHAT THE
HELL SHE WAS TALKING ABOUT.
OKAY.
I’M LIKE, DIDN’T THEY PEDDLED
THE CONSPIRACY THEORY ON RUSSIA
NEARLY FOUR YEARS?
>> YEAH, THAT’S TRUE.
BARACK OBAMA WITH HIS 700 AND
SOME PAGE BOOK.
EVIDENTLY, HE THINKS HE’S GOING
TO LEAD US TO THE PROMISED LAND.
LET’S REFER TO HIM AS MOSES.
MOSES IS THE MASTER OF THE
POLITICS OF PERSONAL
DESTRUCTION, WHICH PEOPLE WERE
SO FED UP WITH THAT IT’S A
MOVEMENT BEGAN AND THEY ELECTED
SOMEONE TO HOPEFULLY GET RID OF
THE POLITICS OF PERSONAL
CONSTRUCTION.
BUT BARACK OBAMA DOESN’T GET IT.
PERSONALLY, SEAN, IN ORDER TO
LET A MAN’S OPINION HURT, YOU
HAVE TO GIVE VALUE TO THE MAN’S
OPINION.
I’M GOOD THERE BECAUSE NO.
HE DOES NOT REPRESENT.
>> Sean: BUT THERE ARE
72 MILLION PEOPLE.
IT’S A RECORD FOR ANY REPUBLICAN
TO GET AN ELECTION.
RAZOR-THIN MARGINS.
HE WAS ELECTED TWICE.
WHEN YOU HEAR A SMELLY WALMART
TRUMP SUPPORTERS AND
IRREDEEMABLE DEPLORABLE SPEC
WHEN YOU ARE RUNNING, BITTER
AMERICANS THAT CLING TO GOD GUNS
GUNS, BIBLE RELIGION.
I THINK IT’S REVEALING BECAUSE
WHAT IS HE SAYING ABOUT WE THE
PEOPLE?
IT SEEMS LIKE IT’S AGAINST ANY
AMERICAN THAT DOESN’T SUPPORT
HIM OR HIS VIEWS, WHICH ARE
RADICAL.
>> Sean: WRITES.
I THINK THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA HAS
BEEN PRETTY SUCCESSFUL IN TRYING
TO MAKE THIS WHOLE ISSUE AN
ISSUE OF ATTACK ON DONALD TRUMP.
HIS PERSONALITY, OR HIS TONE, OR
HIS MANNERISMS, WHATEVER.
IT REALLY AMERICA HAS TO
REMEMBER THAT THE LEFT LED BY
BARACK OBAMA AND STILL
HILLARY CLINTON, BIDEN,
THEREAFTER US, AFTER US.
IF THEY CALL US DEPLORABLE,
BITTER BELIEVERS, ALL THAT.
THEREAFTER WHAT WE REPRESENT.
WHAT I HOPE WE REPRESENT BECAUSE
I WANT TO REPRESENT IT IS TRUTH.
THAT’S WHAT BARACK OBAMA IS SO
ABSENT FROM EMBRACING.
BECAUSE OF HIS FALSE ACCUSATIONS
AND THE UNFOUNDED CRITICISM FOR
PROOF AFTER PROOF AFTER PROOF
THAT HE IS A PURVEYOR OF
UNTRUTH.
IN OUR COUNTRY HAS A TOTAL OF
TRUTH.
WE HAVE TO BE SEEKERS OF TRUTH,
WE HAVE TO BE WILLING TO FOLLOW
TRUTH AND THERE IS SO MANY
UNTRUTHS THAT BARACK OBAMA IS
LEADING PEOPLE TOWARD STILL.
FOR INSTANCE, I TRUTH IS THAT
ONLY LONG ORDER WILL USHER IN
PEACE AND PROSPERITY.
THE SANCTITY OF LIFE, THAT’S A
TRUTH THAT WE SHOULD PROTECT
LIFE.
THE DEMOCRATS PLATFORM IS THE
ANTITHESIS OF THAT.
THE PROVISIONS ABOUT KILLING A
BABY IN THE WOMB.
THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS THAT
BARACK OBAMA STANDS FOR STILL
AND HE JUST DOESN’T GET IT.
THE SOLUTION TO OUR PROBLEMS IN
THIS COUNTRY, IT ALL COMES DOWN
TO SIMPLY LOVING TRUTH.